what's your favorite game then
that's location
i likely just because like i played it
for so long and i started my youtube
career pretty much on legal so it means
a lot to me yeah
again it's like you know you you've been
dating this person for like 10 years and
it's like it's time to let go
but you do have good times with them
it's not like you don't have good times
with them
like you don't play ranked much anymore
right because that's when like i feel
like the game is at its worst but also
at its best in a way playing with if you
have a full stack it could be fun but
that's this case with valerian as well
yeah stack make friends make things fun
right no but leaks one of those games as
well while i feel like if there's one
person in your lobby who's like really
high ranked or on your team it's really
hard to like play with them yeah and
it's like how do you i'm not gonna pick
my friends based on their elo like i'm
not a i'm not a weirdo and you just make
smurfs yeah i guess sorry everyone
yeah yeah i mean like that's kind of
like why i never really get into
competitive games because there's always
like the initial hump where you start
learning a new game it's really fresh
it's really fun
and then like the moment that game dies
for me is when i like pressed like it
started going on the ranked ladder and
then that's when it like the game stops
from being fun to just being like a
choice like a stressful experience like
it's it's like a friendship ender at
some point if you if you go it seems
like a nice idea in your head oh yeah
let's let's rank up together guys and
then like you
like if you want to test your friendship
you go into a ranked game with your
friends on league that will test your
friendship right because not everyone's
going to be the same skill level right
yeah yeah and so if someone you will
fight you will find out who the toxic
people in your friend who are by playing
ranked ladder together weed out the
toxic yeah
literally
do you like uh i don't know okay have
you ever heard of pokemon puzzle league
pokemon puzzles it sounds really
familiar yeah why does it sound familiar
a tetris attack yeah yeah it's like that
but pokemon oh there's pc on me
what's it got to do with pokemon
nintendo 64. oh
oh oh okay okay it's like one i love
that game so much but no one plays it
it's like you know when you have like oh
yeah because it was like when the
dinosaurs were okay but like
to this day when you go to packs or
whatever some conventions sometimes they
have like tetris attack tournaments and
stuff like that yeah
that's yeah yeah it's one of those games
that i think i'm like really good at
like normal place so i stopped playing
it
um
could you still win now would you win i
think i could win did you like speed
some people i don't
so now i'm trying to like get better at
valerie because everyone plays valeran
right yeah so if you're good at valor
you know you'll look cool man like
that's what i look cool i'm gonna be
cool but i can't i'm not good at fps
i'm gonna like like music rhythm games
or stuff like that but like that's not
that's not cool it's battle around japan
is really [ __ ] cool in japan i'm very
excited to go to all like that just go
to the art yeah yeah just master rhythm
game and you will be like
the princess of that article but then
you've realized how [ __ ] you are when
you go to japan you see some of the
people
yeah yeah yeah just see those you just
see those [ __ ]
i've seen them and
they're like they're just insane it's
like work but it's like they're all like
that yeah i know like every time you go
everyone is like serious about it
everyone has like their custom gear like
yeah you go to one of the boobs and they
bring out their [ __ ] glove or
something
are you like the goddamn you know
it's like when they go to like you know
like ddr pump it up machines yeah you
come with like towels and like water
bottles and like backpacks yeah you're
camping oh my god
you know you know shit's about to get
like [ __ ] up when like the it's always
like it's never the guys who are like
fully fully in shape that are the best
that ddr it's like the guys who are like
you know just come out to the
arcade some big dudes i've seen i saw i
remember this like one kind of like
larger gentleman in awe sucker who just
went up to a ddr machine like huge
bottle of water big towel and he was it
would look like it was about to like
work out and everyone at that arcade was
like hold on guys
something something magical is about to
happen yeah he was absolutely tearing us
and there's like 30 people surrounding
him just being like i will challenge you
and he's just like all right step up
honestly sometimes it's intimidating
though because sometimes i just want to
like try out like a nice rhythm yeah you
should try no i do i do love the rhythm
games but like sometimes you see someone
like tear it up in this rhythm game and
i'm just like i don't know how to get it
to start like
he sucked
that's me with like fighting games
though at all
because it's like i always want to try
it yeah but there's always a [ __ ]
prodigy 10 year old on the other side
ready to kick my ass right so also they
smoke at those in japan
some of them
a lot of the ones with the fighting
games on the floor you can smoke if it's
if it's especially like the old-school
kids
yeah it'll be like no smoke on any of
the floor the fighting game floor you
can smell it there'll be ash trays and
stuff and so just it reeks of smoke
though but in the middle of that there's
always that one ten-year-old who's just
destroying everyone
it's it's really interesting i feel like
you see like you see like a almost
authentic side of japan in the arcade
yeah everyone kind of just like come
into this place and just let off some
steam yeah interesting it's the best
yeah i think like the fighting game
community in japan is like way bigger
than say like
what's like what's what's like smash
i don't know is it smash big in japan
it was big right yeah like the at the
peak i think like there was a lot of
like like high level competitors going
to like big smash tournaments in the us
and right evo and [ __ ] but
i don't know about now i know any game
where you don't need to converse with
someone to be good at it like that
that's that's that's like big in japan
you know so rhythm games fighting games
like massive in japan
no words necessary only fierce
it's just like because they want to like
they want to do one thing and they just
want to perfect it yeah it's like the
very japanese way of thinking it's like
i just wanna redo the same thing and
just get very good at this one skill not
to prove it to anyone just to prove
tomorrow it's like a self rewarding
feeling i'm not really sure why like
it's kind of very zen right yeah yeah
yeah it works yeah like i i really want
to get into fighting games but there's
such a big massive jump from just
randomly mashing buttons yeah to like
being even like a competent like being
like just mildly confident of fighting
games that's such a big [ __ ] gap hard
at smash because i just wanted to beat
the people at the party you know at the
party there's always a smash yeah yeah
yeah yeah i just wanted to beat like
some people that was my threshold did
you ever get to that point i don't know
there were no parties culvert hit
it's like all the training got to waste
i think the only time because joey's
like one of the chillest guys i know i
think one of the only times i've seen
joey like genuinely tilted and angry is
during smash why you played connor yeah
oh yeah
this [ __ ] kept playing king k
roll and just [ __ ] down being every
time
i love characters with characters it
feels so fun it's like why would i want
to hit you when i can make you hit
yourself it's the only time i've ever
thrown a controller on the ground oh i'm
just like [ __ ]
something about smash the other day
the other day i was on youtube and then
there's like these whole smash
compilations yeah they're my favorite
they're so funny this is so funny it's
like this whole world opened up and i
just started clicking for like three
hours like the saltiest moment
compilations of smash tournaments
one of ludwig's most popular videos is
that he made a compilation of like top
10 saltiest ice climber moments i think
really yeah and that's like his most
popular videos i didn't even know he
made that video
honestly like part of the reasons i want
to get into fighting game is because the
fighting game community just seems so
fun
like i've seen like so many compilations
on youtube or just like fighting game
community moments and it's just i don't
know how can i how can describe it it's
the perfect mix of just cancer toxicity
but also like no one takes it too
seriously as well yeah
they're very passionate there's a really
funny clip i think it was like a street
fighter 2 tournament or something and
like some convention and there's just
like two people fighting yeah a huge
crowd and this kid just gets absolutely
[ __ ] destroyed and this from the back
just some guy just goes get that boy
some milk
and then he just became a thing in the
fighting game community
as like a thing to just be like he's
tilted get that voice of milk because
like you know gaming now right it's very
like it's been kind of like polished a
bit you know you can't trash talk as
much online yeah and then now and but
like that's why i feel like the fighting
game is such a cool place it's like you
just trash talk
yeah yeah yeah exactly right i love that
yeah it's kind of like it's kind of like
you know like a real like ufc file yeah
yeah yeah where people were trash
talking
yeah i like that do you not do that
anymore and uh like i can't now like
what are some of like films
when they're like really mean to me i
just type
like
yeah you're [ __ ] you know blah blah this
just feels no no that's unoriginal you
have to come up with like [ __ ] oh okay
um yeah it's hard like i'm trying to
focus on the game how can i think of
witty insults like that's that's weird i
mean valerian writes you're dead for
like most of the time i'm here just like
spitballing ideas like yo i'm trying to
like test these ideas i'm messaging
friends like what do you think he's good
oh i'm up he's going deep into the
insult book yeah yeah yeah
yeah well i'm just that guy who's just
like let's try our best guys we can win
this that's why i don't play call games
yeah because i'm that guy yeah yeah
they're just like shut up
i will say one thing i hate about
valerian it's like why it's like one
skin for a gun like [ __ ] like 30
bucks what's up with that
they gotta dude they're a small company
they need to make money
that was the one thing where i was like
what the [ __ ] even league isn't this bad
i mean league sometimes
prestige skins yeah yeah okay those are
pretty gross
i i um you remember elemental slugs yeah
yeah that was like four thirty dollars
yeah it was a lot yeah so i was thirty
bucks yeah yeah yeah what is it like for
one skin but it's like okay well it's
not just one skin it's like ten scales
in the game you can change to an element
and it changes the whole skin and then
you could change a nut to another
element if those elements makes it makes
another element and there's ten in total
and each one has different voice lines
so it's actually ten skins and one does
it change anything about the way the
characters played no no no okay because
if it did then it wouldn't it would
break the game just like aesthetics so
yeah so it's just a really elaborate
aesthetic
yeah but it's really pretty it's my
favorite champion i was really excited
so i got it and i asked my friend do you
want one i think everyone should try it
right so i gave him one and then i asked
another friend i'm like do you want one
too i spent i gave like five friends
like elementary oh my god damn
the other reasons i i used to always get
the 490 mystery skins
i used to love that i don't know
it's like a mystery box it's a mystery
you're playing
you were into gotcha are you telling me
you were into garcia
but i didn't want to feel like i was
paying full price
because if i did that i would feel
ashamed so you got a skin that you
probably didn't even play really what do
you mean i i love one of the odious
skins that isn't spirit guard
i love those
that's you know when you get a skin for
malphite and it would be like the you
know he has like that one what is it
like the shamrock one that one is so
[ __ ] shamrock
they would like just recall him green
and be like kids shamrock
but he was just like early league skins
they just recolored it and called it
something else but now it's just a shiny
pokemon yeah yeah yeah we have stepped
it up yeah i mean now everyone just
looks but all the girls now they make
them look the same in like every skin
it's kind of weird yeah i know but
they're still pretty like i know i know
about this but like my eyes are glazed
over when i see like sparkles and pretty
colors
is is the skins what makes she comes
back to play league whenever whenever
like a new skin like gets released and
you're like damn that looks good do you
only play cute champions i'm not gonna
that's so that does check out i'll just
check out i feel like i know the answers
to this but obviously obviously as
somebody who's been doing league stuff
for a really long time you know league
is kind of going into more of like an
anime direction i noticed do you like
that hell yeah yeah you know i think
they should just go full weeb honestly
at this point just just do it i do wish
they had a little more monsters though i
do like the monsters monsters did you
see that mommy the bellevue they're not
pretty to look at the man
zach is like my favorite character oh
he's like a big bubble gum he's just
great like he's fun i love how he plays
that's great but they know i think it's
also what sells so like yeah
yeah
and all those kind of samurai boys
i mean i mean like league and weeb
culture or all leagues and weeps have
always like just meshed one to one
yeah leagues and weaves right
yeah because like i remember even before
like in the early days of league pretty
much i pretty much everyone who played
league i felt watched anime as well
because like i i'd see so many like
people just talking about anime in my
chat you know when i when i would play
league and i was like oh this is where
all the anime fans are because i
couldn't find them in real life they're
all playing league yeah it'd be like
hisoka fan 69 or something
oh because everyone was playing yasuo
right and you know that if you're a
yasuo player you definitely watch it i
banned the word yasuo in my chat did you
know when you type in yasuo it's just a
it's an emote of someone puking
really hate that champion i firmly
believe that him being created like
dampened my game experience and made me
play like less i hate yeah
i know it's like they took everything
that was bad about yasuo and they like
they made it even worse in yone i hate
those two champions so much like every
time i see it i don't even want to play
anymore so to explain yasuo to you joe
yeah please okay yasuo is a samurai
right
that's it he's he's a he's a very high
skill cap samurai champion right
so
sorry no sorry this high school cup it's
just a really funny way let's see
well how would you say it
he's a character you want to play when
you want to be like edgy like you want
to look a little flashy and [ __ ]
everyone wants to be better than they
are yeah he's very he's a he is a
difficult character
so like how how it always plays out is
when you are against an enemy yasuo
they're like [ __ ] god mode yasuo they
will go like they will [ __ ] solo kill
your entire team and like make you
slowly lose the game right but when a
yasuo is on your team it's guaranteed by
like the force of nature that there will
be the reason you lose the game yeah
they'll go 0-10 and then they'll flame
everyone for like for like sucking up
the game right yeah yasuo plays like the
worst and then they made a brother
called
like his same skill
it's the same thing but with a bunch of
more [ __ ] yeah even more like weird
[ __ ] like self-healing more shields when
it came out i was like in shock i'm like
i don't have two bands i only have one
so that's like i have to ask my friends
ben yoni yeah i mean all the new
characters they release are nuts like i
just yeah like
i hate zoey i hate yeah talia all that
[ __ ] even though that's old now but yeah
it's kind of old yeah
i know i know but like ever since like
that point onwards i was just kind of
like i do think like as league gets
bigger they have like over 160 champions
like there's only so many kids they can
make yeah and like how are you gonna
make each one more unique i guess yeah
it definitely feels like they keep
making it even crazier and crazy like
the new one they announced looked just
like stupid yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] like
dashing like everywhere like even more
than normal now yeah or what's the
samira as well i didn't really like it
like what the [ __ ] is samira doing
oh
yeah
yes
joey looks so lost right now he's like
100 i'm just alive and doing it joe
joyce is vibing right now
yeah because like the only way i find
out about new champions now is because
like when you when i followed like the
esports scene and i see a new champion i
just like i have no idea what oh my god
they picked it they picked the thing and
they're like oh
what is it i don't know
do you still follow the esports scene at
all yeah
why would you you're from the na server
right
i said it okay i said it wrong
i do think back in the day like i'm
talking like season three for ish there
were more story lines like i could
follow you knew everyone yeah yeah yeah
yeah or whatever yeah no it's like i
just lost track i don't know
yeah pretty much you just like follow
faker and uh i can't believe faker is
still like
playing
i know i wonder what's gonna happen to
league when he retires he's like the god
of league of legends at this point
that's insane so fake is like i guess
what's what's the color like the michael
jordan of like league i guess that's
like what's what's what's like the
michael jordan yeah i mean that's fair
enough i mean like i'm trying to think
of like a really like a really great
player
for being yeah heard the name faker yeah
yeah because his name i guess
almost like transcends league itself
because you you might not know nothing
about league but you've heard the name
faker i know that you're fake yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think he chose such a good
name too to be like that icon like faker
it sounds so cool i can't watch his
streams though it makes me sick watching
him like with the camera
like he whips the camera all around it's
like impossible to watch yeah he's like
he like flicks around everywhere and
it's it's nauseating to watch yeah so he
has like hockeys so he has hotkeys where
he can like flick to like different
champions or like his teammates
yeah yeah he uses them but he flicks to
like a teammate for like a microsecond
and somehow that's enough time to garner
the information he needs
i'm just like this is what happens when
you're like just jacked into the matrix
is it you talking about this edit where
like it's something where like he's in a
a fight and instead of flicking someone
edits it so he's opening up solitude
he's playing like solitaire while
fighting it's so good
because it looks real it looks so good
yeah but like yeah i can't watch his
streams but you know it's like pretty
much
it's great watching him play jump king
and pogo start because you're like you
are human it's nice to serve you're not
a god gamer it's like you see him fall a
[ __ ] ton of jump king you're like that's
really comforting
the best guy in the world at this game
also struggled with that one's [ __ ]
jumping jump king yeah
have you finished jump king no
yeah
probably never going to touch that game
it was it reminded me of that other game
what it's a game like that getting over
it getting over it yes yes no no jump
king's way harder is way higher oh
really yeah yeah they're both hard and
they both i gave up on both of them
it's like somehow the jump king even
though it's like a rage game it's still
like you're always getting back to it
yeah it's still like less rage inducing
to me than some league servers
or some league games you know i would
say it was definitely the most one of
the most satisfying moments when i beat
that game
in recent history
yeah
it was really good would you would you
do the uh expansions though no
i i uh i prioritized my happiness so uh
no thank you i say that and i'm probably
going to it's like a drug yeah it was
the worst carpal tunnel i ever got from
playing jump king i've never gotten
carpal tunnel oh my god well i play
because you play with the keyboard
i play with control
so i can sit back that's smart yeah i
should have done that [ __ ] yeah okay
at least she watched her king
yeah yeah at least i did watch arcane
that's true i'm so sorry
i can't believe you didn't watch it
i can't believe i can't believe it's
brought up
watch it again